welcome back everyone thank you for
honoring the process okay um i'm gonna
pick up pace quite a bit because the
first i tell the truth i mean i
um
speaking maybe a bit slower than i
planned so now i'm gonna make up for it
and speak uh double speed but hopefully
we can still
uh get much out of this and i think that
maybe many of you have seen this before
so
the thing is that we have this view of
uh what we talked so far is this view
that looks at uh
capacity and inductive bias or capacity
control in terms of networking
particularly the size of the network is
what we have here and
um
what we uh
in the hypothesis classes you know
functions we can fit within your
internet um and then uh about
seven years ago already eight years ago
almost we did some experiments that for
me at least uh really uh changed the way
i think of many of these things uh and
so even though many of you probably have
seen this plot before i'm actually
curious how many of you have seen this
plot before know what's in here okay how
many who hasn't seen this book before
nobody nobody knew one person okay i'm
still gonna present it because i i mean
this really has been uh for me at least
very significant so the experiment we
did that apparently many of you have
already heard
uh about we fit uh um
networks this is work with the venom
nation board in the rio tamil we fit
networks of uh different sizes uh to
data i mean this is i remember either
cfr mnist this is eminent stating data
and what we looked at is the training
error in the tester and i want to
emphasize that this is not like you know
talked about access this is not run time
right so this is not like over a single
run right so every network we fit
completely separately we took a network
with 18 units with 68 units we know 512
hitting units and with each network
completely fitted from scratch
and what can we see is two things well
first of all the training error goes
down that's not surprising at all and
the more interesting thing is what
happens to the tester right and the
tester initially goes down right and
this is not surprising because you know
we we're the network is bigger and
bigger we have better fit you know the
estimation error is improving that's
great the interesting thing is what
happens past this point so with 64
hidden units
the net the network is uh the the
hypothesis class is big enough to
completely fit the data there's
essentially no estimation error okay and
the question is now
um how the test error is going to behave
and the classic theory based on what uh
spencer told us uh yesterday is now
we're going to talk about uh larger and
larger classes our approximation error
is not going
down sorry so before there's no
approximation right now there's no
estimation error sorry you can um
there's no approximation so now we're
going to start suffering the effects of
the estimation error and um things are
going to get much worse okay so we're
going to they're going to increase in
fact with a thousand hidden units
there's already uh
more parameters here than uh data points
which means i can fit anything i can
like learn i mean the error here should
actually be not like just like this but
like completely through the roof should
be as bad as the null error or maybe
even worse
but if i'm showing you this you already
know that this is not what's actually
going to happen in practice and many of
you have seen this before
and what we see is actually behavior
that looks like this okay so now what's
going on here
so and again i mean
when we
first saw this this was you know we had
to scratch our eyes several times and
and even though this kind of matches
what we
empirically see uh uh in realistic
situations really training neural
networks you know we train larger and
larger networks without any explicit
regularization so the only capacity
controller here is by the size of the
network and yet the error and it must be
the estimation error here is going down
the test error is going down okay
and
and this is very strange and many things
are strange here the fact that it's
going down and not you know first of all
it's not you know going up it's even
going down but again let's focus on this
like uh point here uh where there's you
know a thousand units and over here um
our classic theory is going to tell us
that we can generalize it all because
the capacity of the class is too large
right that we have more you can shatter
anything we can fit different random
labels there's absolutely no way we can
we can generalize
and yet
the network we find does actually
generalize
so so what's going on here and the thing
is that as i tell you at this point
we're really um there are more
parameters and data points so the the
the the model is underdetermined right
so just saying all we did here was we
defined the empirical scrutinizer right
we generally minimized the training
error and we know i found the global
minimum of the training error how do i
know that i found the global minimum of
the training error even though i'm just
doing local search
i don't know whether it's a global
minima
it's zero right i mean it's the
objective is not negative and i found
something with zero error right so it's
definitely a global minima
um but the thing is that there are many
global minima there are many ways of
getting a zero error solution okay and
in fact what i'm going to plot here each
one of these points
corresponds to a zero training error
solution so all of these are valid
global minimum okay
and somehow the global minima
that we found
actually
uh does generalize well okay so why is
it that the global minima that we find
actually generalizes as well even though
it's definitely possible to get lots of
different global minimum another way so
later on there's another experiment that
you probably have already seen it also
in some sense observed
another phenomena they observed the same
phenomena uh and now instead of just
believing me that there's enough
parameters they actually check that
there's enough parameters to fit
everything so this is the the
getting truncated a bit here but i was
over there okay over there it's fine uh
oops go back go back
um
this is an experiment by uh zhang adol
and what they did is they looked at
networks and they said okay these are
many parameters but let's even convince
ourselves really we can shatter they
just empirically shattered right so they
took um
uh random labels and they saw that with
these same architectures we can get
actually completely fit random labels
they get 100 or near 100 accuracy and
random labels so you know that with this
hypothesis class we can shatter and yet
uh when you fit uh
um
when you fit in real data um okay you
also get 100 uh accuracy zero error
that's not surprising because we can say
we can always get zero percent zero
error but you actually also
generalizable you get uh high accuracy
okay of course with random labels you
know you keep then you there's no way of
getting high accuracy high test accuracy
okay
so what's going on here and then the
conclusion here where this is impossible
how come we have a learning rule how can
we have a learning role that on one hand
can shatter anything can get zero
training error always even in random
labels on the other hand can generalize
well okay so
um in this doesn't fit uh in some sense
doesn't fit this the review that spencer
uh presented at least not if you think
of uh this erm uh over class but is this
possible so so let's think again of what
happens here does this mean that we have
to like you know again this is reminding
you the theme of this uh the second half
of tutorial is what do we need to
rethink and what do we already know like
is this something we need to rethink or
is this fits perfectly fine with our
understanding right so what's the
phenomena here let's summarize it we we
see that we have a learning rule right
training the network um that on one hand
can shatter anything like on any data
set even with random labels it can get
zero trading error on the other hand if
it's actually uh the the training data
as real data actually comes from reality
then okay we also get zero training here
because it always gets zero training
here but it also generalizes well
can we have such a learning rule
okay
the answer is of course yes okay we're
used to having such a learning rule
maybe the the simplest example is one
nearest neighbor right so one nearest
neighbor
by definition we always get zero
training here all right because every
point in training set is its own
neighbor so we always get zero training
here and yet we have results that under
some mild assumptions if the data
actually does come from
some reality that has some like mild
continuity assumptions we know that the
test error will actually go to zero
right so again so we always get zero
training here even on random labels but
if the data i'm turning is if the data
satisfies some reasonable assumptions
then we also get a small test there okay
so this is not like by itself something
special but this is with one nearest
neighbor
which doesn't really feel like what
we're doing here because we're doing
something more like erm so can we get
something also with like this rule where
we just minimize something
and also that is something that we're
used to and
it's enough to think about something
like hard margin svm so what's a hard
margin spm learning rule so for a hard
margin spm with a thing of hard margin
spam with universal current like a
gaussian chrome so you have galveston
kernel svm
and with hard margin spm we always
insist on getting on separating uh the
data and we just find the maximum margin
separator so the thing is that with a
graph and kernel i can always separate
the data right so any any finite set of
points is separable with the galvan
kernel right so everything is separable
so even with random labels i would
always get zero trading error
but the thing is that we also know that
if actually reality is
uh uh captured by a low norm predictor
so there is actually a low high margin
which means low norm predictor uh that
uh uh that captures reality then i will
also generalize
okay so again exactly it's time
phenomenal so let's think of it from the
perspective of what we uh talked about
in terms of complexity measure and and
uh
in these sub-level sets and the
capacities so what's going on here when
training a hard margin spm we're looking
for the minimum
maximum margin which is the same as
minimum norm predictor that fits the the
data so if data generated by some
reality here that has small norm okay
then the minimum
predictor is going to be you know of
that size and the relevant sub-level set
of the complexity measure kind of what i
the relevant capacity uh the set i have
to measure its capacity is something
like this and this can be small and i'm
going to generalize what's going to
happen when i fit um
random labels so random labels are not
like i cannot fit them you know in order
to to fit them i really have to use a
huge a very high norm predictor a very
complicated predictor okay so i can
actually fit them uh but i'm gonna have
to go away you know they're much more
complicated you know they're like you
know as complicated or i have to go to
capacity proportional number of points
okay uh and so the relevant sub-level
set is huge and i'm not going to
generalize okay so again so are as we
said our theory is still valid we still
just need to understand the capacity of
each uh set but the thing is that the
the the relevant hypothesis class the
relevant sub-level set that we have to
look at its capacity is not fixed and
predetermined
but rather it corresponds to whatever it
is that fits the the data right so
and this is something and this is
nothing new here this
goes back to the
at least 90s if not before and something
we understand very well okay uh
is this questions about this this is i
think uh okay
yes very much in real life
yeah so that's sorry that's the example
what i uh yeah definitely and that's
that's exactly what we
uh
[Music]
the answer is yes and i'll show you the
system okay uh
uh
okay good uh um okay so as we see
there's nothing like special about the
fact that the learning mode and one has
been zero training and another and uh
generalizes well when and only
generalizes well of course when reality
is simple right so if reality is gonna
how well it generalizes depends on
reality um so this is for uh
um i said for a hard margin svm we can
also see it even in my favorite learning
rule which i already mentioned before
which is the shortest program again this
is maybe not implementable but i think
conceptually it really is the
um uh if somebody asks you know what's
the measure of simplicity maybe this
even matrix would agree that the kind of
universal measure of simplicity is just
you know
the length of this of a program needed
to uh uh to explain uh the data you
agree with that matters you're happy
with the matter just happening with that
right and so this is in some sense maybe
the prototypical learning roads of
course completely unimplementable but if
think of the learning rule that just
outputs the shortest program that gets
your error for any
any labels even random labels i always
have a program that gets zero training
error right that just encodes all the
training set uh it might be very long
right but if reality is actually
captured based by can be captured by a
small program that we i know i'm also
going to generalize right so again this
is not uh special so let's go back to
here and
um we said that we find the
uh a global minimum that actually has
zero uh that actually generally as well
and going back to what's your name
well going back to ahmed's question um
there are uh
uh
um and so um
so
uh so it's not uh really surprising here
but then the thing is that there are
actually also many
global minima here that have horrible
tester right so all of these points
correspond to global minimum of the test
error
going off the training error and they
have horrible tests there they don't
generalize well so why is it that our
predictor generalizes well in particular
we found generalized as well whereas all
these other ones don't generalize well
how do i find these that's much harder
to find them actually uh so the way we
found them is we
we optimized the training error and uh
also having high error and another
a random set of examples we call them
the confusion set okay so intentionally
very in this optimization is much harder
actually i mean it was much much harder
to optimize um but we succeeded in
actually finding them i mean we know
theoretically they exist they're most
global minima are like this but it's
actually much harder to find them okay
if i ignore the exact x axis
then thoughts like this were also there
in the earlier boosting
yeah so i'm very curious what your
thoughts are on like what is new that's
happening here
okay
but it's it's in the context of yeah
i think the first order answer is
nothing there are some differences but
you're right you're right that uh it's
um a surprise completely right that
plugs like this were definitely observed
also for uh this is not the first time
we kind of for uh seeing something like
this and scratching our head you know
exactly for the
same reason okay but let's let's go back
to here and what's uh uh happening here
is that it seems that maybe the the
uh the reason we're generalizing we said
in svm the reason we're generalizing is
you know there are many also there are
many ways of getting zero error and
we're choosing the one which has
smallest norm okay and maybe that's also
what's happening here okay and so in
that case this x-axis which is number of
hidden units and i said
the the theme here is watch the x-axis
doesn't actually measure our real
complexity measure okay
and in fact already uh back in the 90s
um
peter bartlett pointed out that uh for
uh maybe when you talk about super
generalization of neural networks
similar to svms what the more relevant
complexity measure is not the number of
hidden units but maybe some measure of
the norm okay and you didn't ask me here
i asked you to always ask me what's in
the x-axis and no prior maybe if you
didn't ask me what's on the x-axis here
right so i told you what's in y-axis and
i plugged in many global minima
but the what i put into the x-axis here
is also some measure of norm okay it's
some specific normal i don't want to get
into it called the path norm uh that
makes this plot nice
but the point is that indeed these uh
predictors that are very bad okay they
also have very uh high norm whereas the
particular generalized as well is
predicted with small norm okay
um
so uh uh
so so this suggests that maybe the
relevant complexity measure what you're
really doing is not just you know
finding a predictor but by a low norm
predictor but the first question here is
which norm okay so
you can think about uh you know in uh
um you can think about norm that the
normal thing is sum of squares of all
the weights in the system some kind of
forbiddenious norm i can tell you that
if i plotted that and the reason i
didn't plug that on the x-axis here is
it didn't look so would not look so nice
okay
um so the path norm is some other norm
that i don't want to even tell you what
it is because i know it's not the right
answer but it does like make this block
nice you can think of many other
measures of magnitude of the weights
many other norms okay um
if we're saying that the the real uh
complexity measure here is not number of
units it's some kind of uh magnitude
based measure what is what measure what
norm
but
more than that we should ask you know
how you know why are we actually how are
we minimizing this
norm or complexity measure whatever it
is because what we did here you know is
just
find uh just minimize the training error
all we did is taking this class and
minimizing the the training error and we
did minimize it we find the global
minima but as we said all of these are
valid global minimum but somehow our
learning algorithm which was just ready
in descent
return to us not just a global minima
but return to us a good global minimum
we're going to say good this is really
being unfair to the algorithm because
all of these are also completely valid
global minima
but some of the algorithm chose not to
return them but return one that has
maybe small norm or something like this
okay so how is this happening is this
kind of
again is this a new and strange thing
how can the algorithm without being told
so actually not only minimize the error
but also return something that's simple
in some sense
so again this is not something that's
newer we have to oh
um
um not something that's new we have to
go very far and you know whenever
there's something you want to understand
you should always
start with the simplest possible model
that has this uh phenomena and the
simplest possible model is frequently
just uh least squares right linearly
spurs okay so let's look at the linearly
squares problem
and i want to solve this under
parameterized linear least squares right
sorry over parameterized under
determined linearly squares remember
we're talking about learning
undetermined models where there are many
many more parameters than data points so
that's what we're going to look at here
we're going to look at the least squares
problem with many many more dimensions
than equations or data points okay so
it's very easy to optimize this there
are many uh many global minima right
many ways to get zero solution right
there's a whole like
m minus d
sorry d minus m dimensional space of
solutions but if i optimize this with
gradient descent which of these many
solutions am i going to get
what's the answer so what happens if i
optimize this with gradient descent
so i'm going to get the minimum
euclidean norm solution okay um
and
um and the thing is that note that i
didn't actually ask really nissan to
find the minimum clearance solution okay
and the fact and also the fact that i'm
looking at minimum clean alarm is not
part of the optimization problem this
optimization problem is nothing to do
with the new clearly norm okay you might
be confused because there is actually
euclidean norm here but that's actually
relevant i'll get the same thing also if
i replace this euclidean norm with an l1
norm of the error it's still ready in
the center but it's still converged in
the euclidean arm solution
the choice of this euclidean norm is
purely a function of the optimization
algorithm if i change the optimization
algorithm for the exact same
optimization problem
i'm actually going to be implicitly
minimizing some other norm so in
particular if instead of using gradient
descent use coordinate descent okay so i
optimize the exact same undetermined
problem use coordinate descent what am i
go which which predictor am i going to
convert to now i'm also going to convert
to a zero predictor but which is our
predictor am i also going to convert
some euclidean on predictor
okay not quite okay so it's going to be
related to the minimum l1 norm but it's
not going to be exactly minimum not one
norm it's going to be
basically it's going to be the largest
predictor which we know the lars is kind
of similar to this so it's not exactly
the same
it's definitely not going to be the
minion euclidean non predictor okay
okay um
and so we see that
what we're seeing here is that we're
getting a very significant in uh
inductive bias a very significant bias
towards simplicity in this bias to
simplicity
is coming purely from the optimization
algorithm not from the
not from our formulation of the
optimization problem if we change
optimization problem algorithm right we
get a different uh simplicity measure
okay this is for uh for least square
solution
um and note that here it's also a bit
difficult you know here it's actually um
easy to understand uh to characterize
what we get um for currently descended
already which is like this you know the
simplest possible thing is grading the
sentence second uh simplest optimization
algorithm is coordinated and it already
becomes a bit tricky to exactly
characterize
uh fortunately when we talk about neural
networks we frequently don't talk about
minimize the score loss we minimize the
logistic loss um so what happens when
you measure logistic class we can ask
the exact same question so now you know
just talking about logistic regression
or you know maybe the new way to say
logistic regression is we train a
neural network with a single unit with
the cross entropy loss right that's okay
but basically just logistic regression
so we have
data points
x i
y i which i'm going to denote uh you
know
here so a bunch of x i's with positive
labels and negative labels minimum nice
logistic laws okay
and let's assume the data is is in high
dimension so they don't have to mention
it's always been receivable but just
think of the data is linear receptable
um
and so uh what's going to happen what's
going to happen when i minim when i
optimize uh this with gradient descent
right so where um
i'm going to
where is grading nissan going to
converge
okay so i'm going to is a question clear
i minimize this objective with gradient
descent where is gradient descent going
to converge
answers
okay so grading sent is that actually
not going to what do you say
yeah it's not going to converge
actually
it's going to diverge right because
what's going to happen here are you
going to want to drive logistic loss to
zero this is an important thing the only
way the logistic loss is strictly
positive right you can never have
digestive costs be zero you can also
only drive it towards zero and the way
to drive logistic loss to zero is to
pick some um
separating hydroplane any separating
hyperplane okay so at this point and now
uh
drive the
the separator to infinity w to infinity
right and drive the no if i have a
separating hyperplane all the um
all these terms y times uh w x i are
positive okay and now when i take when i
increase w they're gonna be go towards
infinity and the loss is gonna go to
zero and that's the only way to drive
the loss to zero okay
so what's going to happen is i'm
actually going to diverge towards
infinity and this is also something
important to to keep in mind when
talking about logistic loss which is
often what you're talking about talking
about like the norm of the minimizer is
completely meaningless right because
there's no norm of the minimizer there's
no minimizer you're going to go to
infinity and the norm is always going to
go to infinity so also all kinds of
other skill dependent properties like
the hessian flatness all kinds of stuff
like that it's it's meaningless to talk
about it because you know just the more
you optimize the more they're going to
the scale is going to increase okay okay
but nevertheless um what we're going to
happen we're going to go to infinity in
a direction that corresponds to some
linear separator and if i just look at
the optimization problem i can drag this
to infinity in the direction of any
linear separator this linear separator
or this linear
separator
and the question is of all these
possible linear separators in which
direction will i actually diverge okay
or another way to uh to say it is if i
look at the normalized predictor which
which is the direction of the predictor
that's the only thing i care about
because that's going to determine my
separator
that is going to converge uh in in which
direction was it going to converge okay
and now as
people mentioned here i mean the the
answer is again i'm going to converge in
the direction it corresponds to the max
margin separator and the same max margin
okay i want to emphasize it's the max
euclidean or margin so it's the the
the predictor that
minimizes the euclidean norm subject to
a max margin constraint so we still we
again see the euclidean arm popping up
here and this euclidean norm is
specified not from the optimization
problem there's no euclidean normal
optimization problem or just logistic
regression the occluding neuron comes up
only due to the optimization
only from the
the um
optimization algorithm and uh and
um and here again we we can see that if
we change the optimization algorithm we
change you know which norm we're
measuring the margin with respect to uh
in a kind of predictable way so uh with
the
gradient descent
doesn't even say gradient descent we get
this
l2 margin the hard margin spm uh with
the steepest descent we get uh uh and we
distinguish in respect to some norm we
get marginal respect there's no in
particular the important the example
here is coordinate descent so now again
with coordinate 10 now it is exactly
what we get is exactly the l1 margin so
we see that this inductive bias is
coming from the algorithm and an
important thing
to note here is that l1 versus l2 norms
are super different right i mean that
can be the entire difference in learning
and not learning so especially in high
dimensions right l1 gives you sparsity
as far as these like everything right as
far as feature learning which is what
you want to do and l2 does not right and
that comes just from changing the
optimization algorithm
um
okay so what we see here then is back to
here is that um
we're starting to have an understanding
that maybe what's going on here the
inductive device is actually not coming
from an optimization problem but for an
optimization algorithm okay but that
means that if i change the optimization
algorithm okay i'm going to change the
inductive bias and so i'm going to
change the generalization properties
okay and we can in fact see them okay
i'm going to go through this uh very
quickly but what we have here is two
algorithms a blue algorithm red
algorithm doesn't matter at all what
they are the thing is that both of them
are optimal both of them are optimizing
the training error the unregulated
training error and both of them are
finding global optima so both of them
are great optimization algorithms but
what we see is they have very different
generalization properties the blue
algorithm here is generalizing much
better than the red algorithm so somehow
the blue algorithm is finding a better
global minimum and again saying that is
extremely unfair to the red algorithm
because the red algorithm is doing
exactly what we're telling it to do it's
finding a global minima that's the only
thing we told these algorithms but
somehow
the the the implicit bias that's encoded
inside these algorithms is different and
the implicit bias that's called in the
blue algorithm is better than the one
that encoded in the red algorithm by
better it seems to capture this reality
better right maybe on a different
reality it'll be better and be different
okay um
see another example let me skip this
okay so um so
the picture we're getting here is we're
saying that actually
um
the
the the inductive bias is not coming
from the
the optimization problem formulation
from the hypothesis class it's coming
from uh the algorithm right and so in
order to understand your neural networks
we really need uh to understand what the
bias of different algorithms is
understanding your uh what did the what
inductive advice correspond to and then
understanding that you know inductive
bias or complexity measure and um how it
might be good for generalization it's
been so if you add a little bit of
explicit regularization that might maybe
you're regularizing with l2 l1 norm when
the implicit regulation is for the uh or
explicit bias is the l2
do you expect it to kind of like
interpolate between these two okay so so
that's a good question so what ben is
asking is what happens if i also add a
bit of explicit resolution so in these
experiments um
we
in our experiments we actually didn't
have any extra synchronization we did
try actually also
well we tried really stopping but that's
not what you need because that would be
tight optimization algorithm um but the
zhang experiments did actually
experiment also with a tiny bit of
explicit bias actually also some
experiments i didn't experience we did
try some exclusive nice
the question is what's going to happen
so now um i have
the other answer is more complicated so
first of all
for linear models if i add explicit bias
once i have explicit integralization
then at least if this realization is
strictly complex if i had even a tiny
tiny bit to filter organization then the
global minimize unique the problem is
convex i'm going to get there it doesn't
matter which optimization algorithm
means okay so so in that sense the the
algorithm doesn't matter
but things become a bit trickier if i
actually only optimize for finite amount
of time okay so take that
even if that is particularly important
okay
talk about when we have talked about so
mentioned now for logistic regression
for example it takes a very very very
long time i mean you never really get to
the option right so symbolically it's
not going to change what you're going to
get to but with finite amount of time
you might still see a change
in defense and then you can maybe
see something before but for not for
non-convex models the situation is much
more complicated because for non-convex
model if you have a tiny bit of
fertilization
there might be locally strictly convicts
but there's still a question of which
law you know which uh uh
vessel are you gonna get to which of
them are are you gonna get to and we
don't really understand this but it
seems that for an unconvex model
if you had a bit of a tiny bit of
fertilization the implicit bias of which
region are you at all going to get to is
still very significant and maybe even
more dominant than this tiny above
amount of consistent bugs but that's not
something we understand okay
okay uh let's go back uh
to here um
so okay so um
so what you're saying is the bias comes
from the optimization algorithm not
hypothesis test
in fact what i'd argue is that maybe
when we're training a deep network we're
really training these huge networks this
highly over parameterized undetermined
networks and maybe they're really big
enough we we talked before about this
universal approximation results and i
kind of this the universal approximation
results saying that they're irrelevant
because they don't you know
they don't combine with the capacity
control but actually we're not getting
capacity control from the hypothesis
class anyway but maybe from this other
complexity measure and maybe these
results are relevant that in practice we
are actually optimizing uh we are
actually learning using networks that
are large enough to conceptually capture
all functions and i would argue that's
really how we should think of
deep learning we should think of deep
learning is learning using an infinite
size network like similar to you think
about svms svms correspond to infinite
dimension spaces so we shouldn't be
afraid of infinities we're really
learning using an infinite infinite size
network so you can really capture all
functions okay
um and you know i can say that because
indeed you know from our perspective
once we're well beyond the shuttering
being able to shatter then from the
perspective of our data you know
hypothesis that's really isn't limiting
functions uh limiting the functions at
all right and when i argue is that yeah
we're really conceptually think about it
as in is infinite networks and all
functions and in practice maybe use some
like finite uh
architecture the only reason using a
finite architecture is because you're a
computer scientist and you can only do
finite things you know the same way that
when you use um
um when you you do some kind of a
numerical uh uh
procedure you think you know
you think about it in terms of reels but
none of you have ever actually
implemented a real number on a computer
it's impossible to actually work with
real numbers in the computer right what
we can work with is floating point
numbers what's a floating point number
it's some kind of finite precision
truncated approximation for a real
number so we think we're working with
reals but actually we're working with
these truncated representations and that
that's maybe what we're doing here we
should think that we're working with
infinite dimensional networks and in
practice maybe we're working with some
finite truncation of them just so we can
represent them in the computer but in
the same way that if you have uh
if you're uh implementing some
numerical uh procedure right you're
finding i don't know the qr
decomposition of a matrix then first of
all you think about it how does this
work over the reals you think of real
linear algebra for the reals and you
think of your your algorithm over the
reals okay and then you also have to
worry that it's actually going to be
numerically stable and even with this
finite position this finite truncation
it's still going to be fine okay and
maybe not like you know if you do
gaussian elimination then maybe it's
fine over the reels but not fine with
the trunk with the with the truncation
right so it's definitely something you
have to worry about but if your
numerical precision only works because
of this finite truncation right so i you
know if if you have a numerical
procedure that would be incorrect over
the reels but somehow
happen to be fine because you're using
floats
then you're doing something wrong right
that doesn't seem right right and you
first have to understand how we realize
and this is a i'd argue how we should
understand this also first understand
your infant dimensional networks and
then
worry about you know how um you know how
well they're represented with the
truncation so it's again similar to what
matu did yesterday we're talking about
infinite networks but then also worried
about okay just how big is infinite
yeah
very sensitive and unfortunately i'm not
going to talk about it today but we have
lots of work and i'll mention it later
on in like three seven
half a sentence okay okay so basically
what i'm claiming is we're really
optimizing over the space of all
networks and the thing is that the only
thing that's important is what is the
inductive bias algorithm like what
directions the algorithm uh uh
like to go let me actually skip this um
okay so
so let's so you might be thinking i'm
like a bit crazy thing that really we're
optimizing you know my viewers are
optimizing overall functions and the
only thing that's important is you know
we're optimizing using particular
procedure which is grading descent over
over
uh you know the the parameterization we
have and the only thing is important is
like how do we optimize over the space
and what is the optimization algorithm
over the space of all functions and you
might be
thinking i'm a bit uh crazy saying that
i'm a bit exaggerating really can we
really think about all functions how can
we get something useful by optimizing
overall functions so
let me show you another um
experiment we did that and either to my
list of fairy little experiments this is
with the
uh suryagan sakaramos and other uh
co-authors um and this is for metrics
factorization for uh sorry metrics
completion problem so for metrics
completion problem you have a partially
observed metrics you can think of it as
you know movie ratings for you know
movies and the x-axis and users and
y-axis or something like that um and you
want to complete the unobserved entries
you know predict uh which you know how
people are going to like other movies
okay
and
how are we going to solve this we're
going to formulate as an optimization
problem right in this optimization we're
going to take the uh metrics uh the the
uh we're going to optimize over all
possible matrices okay x
um and we're going to just minimize the
error to our observations okay or our
training here
does this make sense
no why does it not make sense
so this is optimization problem makes
sense this is like a good is this a good
procedure for doing matrix completion
why not
it's completely stupid right
then why doesn't it make sense
just copy that you fill in whatever
entries you want
yeah i mean this is a completely stupid
thing right it's super easy okay that
would be super easy to optimize right
but just getting zero training or it's
like training a huge network right
getting to zero training or it doesn't
do something good i can just copy the
observed entries and put in like you
know ignore the other put zero and all
the other put seven and all the other
put like you know 45 and all the others
put some sequence i know the digits of
pi and all that is whatever i want right
it doesn't make any sense whatsoever
it's the stupidest thing ever okay uh
but nevertheless this is exactly what
we're going to do except the way we're
going to represent x is a product of two
matrices u times v so what do we do here
and know that u times v are not like the
dimension is not constrained here so u
times here the same dimensionality is x
okay so i didn't change the optimization
problem at all this is exactly the same
optimization problem i'm still
optimizing over all matrices like all
functions here is all matrices right um
the only thing is i i changed it from a
very simple convex optimization problem
that you can easily solve but it has too
many parameters to an equivalent problem
right these two problems are completely
equivalent to an equivalent problem that
has even more parameters and now it's
hard to solve it's non-convex right but
this is exactly what we're doing in deep
learning right we're making things more
non-convex and more complicated adding
way too many parameters okay it's the
exact same optimization problem so it
doesn't make sense in the exact same way
it's very actually you know if i don't
insist on using gradient descent it's
very easy to solve this optimization
problem how can i solve this
optimization problem very easily
how do you find okay i want to define a
global minima give me in three seconds a
global minimum of this optimization
problem
right so certainly i think said copy y
into u complete it to zero and set v to
the identity right super easy to solve
and it's completely meaningless it's
useless right but we're not gonna solve
it this way we're gonna solve it the way
we do deep learning we're going to solve
the gradient descent and now we're going
to ask if we do grading center and u and
v okay
what are we going to get okay and this
is what we get so
what we see here is first of all the
training error the training error this
is gradient sentence x and this is
gradients in univ the training error is
zero in both cases so we actually
succeeded in finding zero training error
solutions interested in solving the
optimization problem okay for x it's not
so surprising because it's convex for u
and v it's actually a bit surprising
it's not a convex optimization problem
that obviously would get minimal but
maybe not too surprising so uh um we do
do that but more interesting let's look
at the tester okay so if we do gradients
in over x the test error is
as good as nothing the only reason it's
70 percent here and that 100 is because
i observe 30 of the entries right
because i'm all i'm doing is memorizing
basically i'm not doing anything here
but amazingly when i do granny sending
you and v i actually get pretty small
tester definitely much much better than
chance like of something like 10 tester
right so i actually am
introducing here the optimization did
introduce some useful inductive bias
that actually enabled me to learn in
this case and i should tell you that in
this case
of course there was some hidden
structure here there was a
real advice because otherwise i can't do
anything
but the algorithm didn't know if right
the the real thing is the reality is
like approximately lower q okay um
[Music]
yeah but it's not just the algorithm
right okay so i can let me let me let me
get that
okay if
before we change from like
this red algorithm is the blue algorithm
and it's slightly changed and stuff
grading says so this is gradient set
with exact line search
instead i can do gradient center with
very small step size okay this is a
worse optimization algorithm in the
sense that it's going to take much
longer to convert right because i'm
taking really small steps it's going to
eventually get to going in as well but
take much almost optimization algorithm
it's bad but somehow in terms of if it's
inducted by us it's actually better okay
so we actually improved the neck device
in our areas instead of ten percent
about five percent okay
and so this is a think of what we did
before is again we changed the
optimization algorithm we
we actually improved the inductive eyes
but i do want to to keep in mind the
scale here so the huge improvement here
was when we not when we change you know
gradient descent versus you know uh you
know not when we change the priority of
the with momentum without momentum step
size no step size this didn't make a
change but this was a small change the
big the surprising change is the change
between nothing in something okay or
nothing in the lot and that change came
from as as uh prior he pointed out by
not saying oh instead of grading descend
i'm going to use coordinate descent but
by actually changing what i would call
the parameterization right by optimizing
over different optimization variables
and we'll talk about that um in a second
so now to answer uh your arkham's
question i think you asked it okay am i
getting low rank here well okay so what
i'm getting in this case is i'm getting
the minimum nuclear solution which is
actually a bit different than the
minimum rank solution here um and when
we initially posed this we said oh do
you always or always in some sense do
you kind of generally get you know
in the in some limiting way get the
nuclear minimum term solution and we
showed that in some sense uh yes and if
that was true that would really kind of
complete the picture here so what
whenever we identify that means that for
this deep learning procedure we i we
identify the actual complexity measure
that we really that's really the true
inductive bias we show how the
optimization algorithm minimizes it and
then we can combine it with results we
already understand uh about the
statistical properties of the million
nuclear solution right we know that
actually we can bound the complete the
we know
that the nuclear norm actually does
provide us a good approximation for
reality if reality is approximately low
rank and it has a
small capacity sub-level sets and we can
kind of complete the entire story right
but now that what we did is we're trying
to separate between understanding the
implicit bias and what is it implicitly
minimizing and then understanding that
as a complexity measure okay um
it turned out that uh uh some follow-up
work by thank you my uh students showed
that this is the case in some specific
special cases but more recent work
showed that that's not generally the
case we still don't know exactly what's
happening here it's it's
some
it's still very related to the nuclear
norm uh but it's not exactly it's
definitely not the minimum rank um
okay um so this is yeah so for the
previous case to show
so does that just depend on the
parameterization yeah no so that's
excellent question so the minimum sga
finds an enormous solution for
uh uh just that's only true for the for
uh linear regression
okay so that's a very expensive thing
and uh what's happening here
well let me get back to that in a second
okay because that's related to the
product's question i'm gonna
i'm very happy asking all these
questions because they actually those
questions they know how to answer so
um okay but let's just see another
example uh yeah
sorry in the experiment uh where you got
minimum nuclear norm of x as a solution
uh where the resulting u and v uh
dependent on like how are they dependent
on the minimum nucleons
uh were there some factors of uh they're
not okay
i'm not sure what
what you're getting at telling you that
they are
um
okay so um let's get so already i claim
that that this is already a neural net i
mean this is like a you know two-layer
neural network uh
linear cancer but that's sort of the
things that actually look more like you
know than decent terms of diagrams uh so
we already talked about in neural
networks we train a single unit neural
net also known as logistic regression we
know we get the hard margin spam
solution
what happens if we train still talking
about linear activations or um uh train
a um
a larger network by a larger linear
network so what's this uh what's going
on what's a linear network all the
activations are linear which means the
output is a linear function of inputs
so again
i'm not just training a linear model
here really right so my all functions
all functions here is all linear
functions right because i'm still just
in space i can't go beyond these linear
functions and this doesn't make any
sense why would i represent a linear
function in this stupid way using a
linear neural net but we already solving
matrix factorization is actually
changing the parameterization changing
our representative function can actually
introduce uh in this uh interesting
inductive bias so we can ask what
happens if we train a fully connected
linear network with gradient descent
okay i'm going to convert to some linear
predictor some linear particular it's
going to separate the data but which
linear particular it separates the data
okay an answer is actually pretty boring
we're still going to convert to the max
euclidean norms
the max margin solution of the
equilibrium some minimum solution with
margin of one same hard margin spm we
actually didn't gain anything by having
more units
um but if we switch to convolutional
networks things become more interesting
so net we're still talking about linear
networks so we're still the space of all
functions is all linear functions but
now we present them using these linear
convolutional network okay so all the
units have the same weights but kind of
rotate right so it's a rank one
of
rank one full width uh
um cyclic convolution okay
and now what happens if i train this
with grading you said so again the
optimization problem is still i'm just
doing basically i'm just doing logistic
regression with a strange representation
i'm still just minimizing you know
searching over linear uh predictors but
uh what happens if i train this with the
gradient any guesses some of you
probably seen this part
what i've done
yeah
in this case what you're going to get
you're also going to get to max margin
but instead of respecting your cleaning
arm you're going to get to max margin
with respect to so at least if you have
one convolution so one hidden layer
you're going to get to max margin
respect to the l1 norm off the
in the frequency domain of the predictor
so you're going to get kind of sparsity
you're going to find predictors there
are spars in the frequency domain okay
so this is actually very rich inductive
bias and again it only comes from the
optimization because the the problem
formulation here is basically you're
just doing linear
logistic regression you're just finding
a linear predictor but the optimization
the way we're doing the optimization
determines which linear predictor
defines the actual complexity
measurement okay um
this is a one in the layer with more
hidden layers you get something that
corresponds to even you know to this uh
two over depth quasi norms or if you
have two ten layers you get the 0.2
quasi-normal it's like more and more
sparsely inducing so you get things that
look like this this is uh with a fully
connected network you just get amino
cleaning arm predictor it doesn't have
very clear
uh frequencies with the one-hit layer
convolution you already see a very uh
definite frequency and with the depth
five you know it's a
super sparse and frequency domain so
very clear
frequency so we already saw two examples
of how i'm optimizing over the space of
all functions and just the way i'm doing
the optimization determines what i'm
going to get in a very rich and
meaningful way one case all functions
was all all matrices which you can think
of as all functions from index pairs to
values that's you know all functions and
here all functions is all linear
functions but what about really all
functions like you know from r to r or
something like that okay so let's look
at all functions from r to r uh so that
i can capture using a even a single
hidden layer uh reload network can
capture all functions so let's think
about training a single hidden layer
relu network and i promised you we're
going to not limit the size so infinite
width singleton layer real network so
now i can really capture all functions
okay
and i'm going to train that with
gradient descent so i'm going to get the
zero error right i'm going to actually
fit my
fit my data but the question is there
are many ways of fitting the data right
which uh
which function that fits the data i'm
going to going to prefer what's my uh
what's my inductive bias here and the
answer it's easy to state at least with
for univariate functions right if the
input is just a single unit there's
functions from r to r but this is
already interesting right now
you spend a lot of time in high school
just filling functions from r to r okay
uh maybe also after so
and the answer here is if on all
functions you're going to pick the
function minimizes
the integral of the absolute value of
its second derivative okay so what does
that correspond to right that's kind of
some kind of smoothness measure right
you're going to prefer functions that
are smooth in this way or simple in this
way going back to this word simple okay
so this is exact same thing so this
makes sense right this is a very
reasonable smoothness measure or
simplicity measure
but it definitely did not come out for
formulation right our formulation was
just minimize the training error over
the space of all function that i
parameterized in a particular way
but we see that this pops out from the
way we're doing this optimization okay
uh this is for univariate functions
where you can extend it for uh
multivariate functions again we can
characterize it although it's a bit uh
trickier to write down it comes out to
the higher order derivatives of the
radon transform
so in all of these cases we see that we
are actually optimizing overall
functions and all the inductive bias is
determined by optimization so now to
answer
uh priya's question and i think tyler's
question also there
does it all amount you know what we did
here when we say the change optimization
algorithm at first they told you of an
optimization algorithm grading descent
coordinate sent can be a big difference
but here we're just talking about
grading descent what we're changing is
really the parameterization but but
changing the parameterization the if i
think of it in the perspective of the
space of functions
it changes how i do the local search
over function so the way you should
think about it is what's the the
geometry under which i do the local
search how am i navigating the space of
all functions and changing the
parameterization definitely changes them
so
um you can really you can just think of
the parameter space in the function
space what i care about is what happens
in the parameter space and what happens
is maybe that in function in function
space in parameter space maybe i
you know i both have to think about
what's the geometry look like in
parameter space and that's maybe
relatively simple right looks like you
know symbols and it still depends
optimization algorithm but this is maybe
a relatively small difference okay um
and the bigger difference is how when i
change the parameters the
parametrization
how it induces a very different uh uh
geometry and function space so it's a
combination of both of these and i i
would call both of these the
optimization algorithm because part of
the choice when i'm optimizing is when
am i doing readiness and with the
spectrum right that's from my
perspective part of my uh
my optimization algorithm so but this
means that if i tell you you know i i
kind of told you the beginning that the
hypothesis class doesn't matter you can
think of it as the architecture doesn't
matter it's just representation of all
functions the architecture does matter
but the way the architecture matters is
in the in it it's not that the
architecture determines your hypothesis
class it's not that the architecture
determines your capacity okay what the
architecture deter determines the way
the architecture is important because
the architecture determines
the geometry of the search in the space
of all functions okay and this is kind
of how maybe we should think about you
know the effective architecture which is
a very different way of thinking about
the architectures determining a model
class okay
and so things you know at the end of the
day the inductive device is determined
by a combination of of multiple things
probably the most important thing is
this architecture is choice of
parameterization
the second but still important thing is
kind of how you do the local search
inside here you do coordinate gradient
descent what's the geometry inside here
and then also important but like much
much less so that's going to be the
difference between that you know 10
percent error and 5 percent error
is the specific of optimization
initialization batch size you know step
size stuff like that okay um and again
now when i'm saying the difference in
ten percent and five percent is that
significant or not i don't know like you
know
people make a huge difference over the
difference between 3.64 error and three
point six one percent there but in terms
of understanding what's going on what i
care about is the difference in ninety
percent error and three point six four
error whatever i said before right um
we're still also looking this because in
extreme cases that can also make a huge
difference um
uh yes okay so just to summarize uh uh
discussion of inductive bias before uh
we move on um so
much of our work uh uh then
also i should say work of many others we
focus on this like trying to understand
things using the complexity measure you
know what i would say the complexity
measure approach and this really means
trying to kind of disentangle and study
two different questions one is
take optimization algorithm and ask you
know a possession of the ingredient
descent usually over a prioritization
and ask what is the complexity measure
that it induces okay um
so we identify uh this complexity
measure for example for grading descent
over uh um
uh
okay we had all these examples before
like for example this news um uh
bridge penalty in the frequency domain
and then we can uh uh
we can ask the the
uh generalization and and uh
approximation properties of this complex
division right and ask this question
enough you know um what's the
understanding the capacity of the
sub-level sets of this complexity
measure and how well the captures
reality okay and so much of our work has
been kind of in here and
thinking of you know how both
how does optimization affect this
inductive bias mostly as i said in terms
of different parameterizations different
architectures but also different choices
and this is like for example the
initialization scale that was mentioned
is very crucial uh and can make a big
difference in like not just between like
you know ten percent and five percent
reason show that like can make a
difference between uh at all being doing
something useful and not doing something
anything useful though i'm not going to
talk about this today but i can refer
you to our uh
uh
our paper in that um and other things
because another question that to me
right now the most interesting questions
stuff we're something we're still trying
to understand is what the effect of
stochasticity if i use batch gradient
descent or gradient with a very large
step size and probably is going to use
stochastic gradient instead maybe with a
very small
let's say stop saying batch size i'm
going to use a large batch size and
probably it's going to used to cast a
gradient maybe with a very very small
batch size
okay we're going to both maybe
eventually optimize get zero error but
is there going to be a very big
difference the fundamental difference
between the inductive bias i'm going to
use the complex the implicit complexity
measure i'm going to have and the one
that prager is going to have and that's
still something i think as a community
we're still trying to understand
um
i
um
i i should just uh
um
i should just say as a disclaimer that i
do think there's a lot of uh to be
gained from this complexity measure
approach but we have to also be
cognizant of the test limitations and
they're definitely
there are phenomena that we know cannot
be exactly explained by uh by you know
by separating to these problems identify
uh a complexity measure that's
simplistic minimized by the algorithm
and then studying it uh but um
you know
there's still a lot to be gained by it
and also it's important to understand
what can't be gained by it you know we
can talk have and don't think anybody
this week is going to talk about this
but there's a lot of uh current research
about this but i actually want to move
away from inductive bias so before you
ask any more questions we're going to
switch to the next slide uh do you have
a question to ask
yeah so in this picture the structure
the story here is like at a particular
parameterization there is some influence
or some interactive others and as you
change like you know picture you should
change the size of the network
and it looks like as you increase the
size the implicit bias which is induced
is better because the generalization is
better
uh and what i said okay actually i think
i'm going to get to that yeah so you're
asking why is that yeah okay excellent
question so
look at this
it's a question that's a question okay
so what we explained so far right is why
is it that over here we don't generalize
you said you were not generalizing
because you know the the
network size is not providing capacity
controllers that's because the x axis is
not really not the bias the real
inductive device is uh some measure of
norm or scale we maybe don't know what
it is but that's really what's giving us
generalization
but why is this decreasing here okay i
didn't tell you why is it decreasing
okay is that new and now again that's
maybe not too surprising because um
under my view the real object is an
infinite dimensional network so really
the real thing is way over or you can
with this pointer point like off the
board but like you know infinite size
and so what happens is that's really
what that's the gold standard we want to
and we're getting as we have higher you
know more and more units we're better
approximating it in the same sense that
you're going to get better results if
you use if you're doing some numerical
calculation then if you increase from
your 16b to 32 bit to 64 bit floats
you're
you're going to improve your accuracy
okay your things are going to be better
because you're approximating things
better okay
and again that's actually not something
that's new we see this behavior and
maybe the best place to see it and the
easiest place to see it is if you're um
you're doing gas and kernel svm i keep
going back to gaussian chromospms
because i really think that captures
like all the phenomena obviously we're
seeing here so you're doing gas in
kernel speed so grabs and kernel spms
correspond to using a kernel what's a
kernel the kernel is just a
representation of an infinite
dimensional feature space right so we
are working in fundamental space
and we okay fine we have this
representation theorem that allows us to
directly work with infinite dimensional
space but suppose i don't know the
representative theorem i can still
actually uh an alternative approach that
actually in practice is frequently uh
very fruitful is to look at a
finite dimensional approximation to our
infinite dimensional space and that's
exactly what we do when we use a random
features approach right so what's random
feature approach to gaussian kernels we
just approximate our gaussian kernel
using a finite number of random features
as number of features goes to infinity
we approximate uh we get a perfect
approximation for a dozen chrome okay
and so now you can think of this
x axis here as number of units is like
number of random features we're going to
use so what happens now when we increase
the number of features when you're
increasing vitamin when we increase the
dimensionality okay this is now the
dimensionality when you increase the
dimensionality we get better and it
doesn't actually the generalization is
not coming from the low dimensionality
the capacity control is not coming from
the dimensionality that's coming from
the norm right but as we increase the
dimensionality we get better and better
approximation from the gaussian kernel
and so we're bettering capital we're
better approximating you know we always
get some number the norm that we're
actually minimizing is a better
approximation of the real norm we care
about and so things will you know our
inductive bias can you know becomes
better and better inductive bias then we
converge to the real thing okay so this
is in another way to see it another
example which maybe is makes for a
simpler story to understand although
it's a bit different
and
goes back to metrics completion and
metrics factorization as you see there's
very few problems i actually understand
svms and metrics completion are pretty
much you know almost the only two things
i understand and luckily you can get a
lot just by them so for matrix
completion
new metrics completing videos matrix
factorization approach and then
you can say that well maybe what i want
to do is instead of having a capacity
control which is the rank which kind of
corresponds if you think of movies the
rank corresponds to how many factors
determine whether people like movies or
not so limiting to x7 corresponds oh you
think that there are only seven factors
determine how many people like movies or
not it turns out that a much better
inductive bias in practice i mean this
is general question but reality as i
said is not to limit the number of
factors but to limit their magnitude
that corresponds to meaning the nuclear
norm or maximum maybe some some norm
measure uh
of the metrics and that means oh there's
not seven factors determined there might
be an infinite factor number of factors
that determine how much people like
movies but their overall importance is
bounded
but now what we can do is again we can
that corresponds to to explicitly
regularizing uh the
um
um uh uh the norms of fue and v of the
factors or you can just think of it as
the uh the nuclear norm of x but now the
problem is if i'm looking at something
like you know uh the netflix or movie
lens mattresses their mattresses are
size like like a million by a hundred
thousand i can't actually represent the
metrics of size a million by a hundred
thousand so i'm actually gonna for
computational reasons represented as a
low rank matrix as u times b so again my
my representation of x is u times z as
the lower arc matrix is not because of
statistical reasons it's purely because
of computational reasons
now i can ask what happens if i increase
the dimensionality of this
representation okay increase the rank of
x or still i'm i'm actually learning by
explicitly minimizing the the nucleon in
the answer and you see this very clearly
and empirically is that the higher and
higher the dimensionality the better
results you get right because the higher
thing of it is you really want to
minimize nuclear norm if i use a rank uh
50 metrics and
ben has access to much much better
computers than me and with much more
memory and uses a rank 70 metrics or
actually let's go to realistic figures
when we did this i use the rank 300 and
users rank 500 okay
then we're we're both going to minimize
the nuclear norm who's going to have a
smaller nucleon or me that with a rank
300 or been with a rank 500.
okay so ben is necessarily going to have
some smaller nuclear because whatever
nuclear arm i can get ben can also get
it but he can maybe use his additional
200 dimensions to drive the nuclear arm
even smaller okay and so he's actually
going to generalize better and
definitely see this empirically and
again this is another example of how
things improve
when
the dimensionality increases because
again the dimensionality or the
important thing is dimensionality does
not control this is not a statistical
thing it doesn't actually give you
statistical benefit it's only
computational compromise computational
memory so forth
the true yeah
yeah so it's an excellent question i'm
not going to be talking about today
although i can spend another art talking
about the
ntk and then
so
um
the ndk is exactly you know you know
especially one infinite dimensional
model and
the
um as you said
i don't it doesn't i don't think it
actually captures what's going on in the
neural networks and thing is that um the
ntk is a
you when the network go the net which
goes to infinity it
with a particular scaling of other
things you approach the ntk
and i would argue that that's just not
the correct kind of uh
scaling limit to take if you take this
scaling in a different way and this goes
back to i think you ask about the
initialization scale so if you look at
the paper with the uh blake woodward so
um the woodworth at all there's uh paper
and we exactly show that as you take as
you increase the width if you scale the
initialization scale appropriately you
you know if you scale it inappropriately
you get to the ntk limit if you scale it
appropriately you get to a different
limit that is meaningful and is good so
okay so
so you're right that if you do things uh
incorrectly and i think
uh talked well wait we saw it yesterday
right i think oh i think you pres uh
spencer presenting some of petum's
results is p-tom's still here i know
uh maybe we'll see these results i don't
think we'll see later on this week that
in fact
if you don't think do things correctly
then things actually become worse when
you increase the dimensionality but
again it's because you're not a dark
it's because you're not doing things
correctly okay
um okay so let's go back to here and
so
the the um so so far i only talked to
you about how we actually know
everything that's i think for the most
part uh true like all or trying to
convince you that all the statistical
theory uh that we developed all the the
understanding of machine learning
different over the decades definitely is
applicable also to deep learning we just
you know we definitely see you know what
is the complexity measure what's the
implicit bias you know how it's capacity
control we have to answer all these
questions but the frame the general
framework is still valid and can used to
explain all these phenomena
but there's one thing that really
doesn't exactly fit okay um and it's
maybe not related to deep learning uh
but it is something we noticed as a
community only in the past few years
and that's the the following that what
we're doing here and telling you that
what's actually happening is i'm
actually minimizing some other
complexity measure but i'm not doing srm
what i'm doing is actually what i'd call
mdl right so we said that what you
where's my pointer
okay we said that we want to be uh you
want to pick a predictor somewhere on
this path to balance between complexity
and air but
what we're all these uh implicit bias
things what they're doing is they're
actually putting a predictor that's the
minimum norm predictor with zero error
so that's this extreme point that
corresponds to lambda goes to zero of
this balance okay so we're picking this
predictor always and not something here
okay so we're not bringing some generic
erm it's a very special erm but it's an
extreme point of this balance and that's
not what we're supposed to do right what
we're supposed to do is we're supposed
to balance fit and uh uh you know what
we were told to do is to balance fit and
and uh and complexity okay not just the
extreme point
and yet we are succeeding in learning
even in noisy situations even situations
where there is a positive approximation
so really we should be balancing we're
succeeding in learning even
more and we're in this extreme point
right so we go back to this result in
particular we see that even if we get
you know i'm saying that this is nice
situation because the test accuracy is
far from zero we still get about 15
percent error and yet somehow it's fine
to get you know where we're 16 learning
even we're trying the training error to
zero even though our classical theory is
going to tell us not to do that let's
remind us the classic theory and then
goes back um
so i think slides from my my second
lecture in my machine learning course
you know you want to fit some data you
know again that's the univariate data
you want to fill it with the simple
number so what happens when you change
the degree of the pronoun right so
degree zero polynomial has a very bad
fit that's very bad okay
if we increase the degree we can get
better and better fit right and so forth
but what's going to happen at some point
so the red points here are the training
points and the green points or the test
points at some point we're going to fit
the red points very well but we're going
to start over fitting the red points
right and we're going to set the the
green points even worse right when you
get to the green line here i can
perfectly fit the red points that's that
extreme point in the curve right when i
get zero error maybe using the minimum
degree to get zero error but this is
still going to completely overfit and
get very bad uh test error that's not
what we're supposed to do okay
and so
um right so we get these curves these
are the classic curves this is exactly
from this data
we get the test error is the the red
line initially it's decreasing because
we're getting better fit but at some
point and the data here was actually
generated by two by two dimensions the
right the uh
uh degree there is two
here the estimation error is starting
increasing and we're over fitting okay
and we get uh we know that overfitting
is bad right so um
we have lots of uh books and all the
books all the courses tell us that
overfitting is bad that we should never
you know predictor that really gets your
training or as you have been generalized
poorly so again just to clarify i think
yesterday also explaining by overfitting
so every step over here we're under
fitting under fitting means that we're
not even capturing the signal
overfitting means that not only are we
capturing the signal we're starting to
capture the noise or fitting the noise
that's from my perspective there's a
vision of overfitting or we're fitting
the noise we're thinking something that
our we can't actually fit okay because
it's random or it's beyond the reach of
our uh of our model class okay
and this shouldn't work and yet we're
seeing that that um
should be somewhere here
where where you know this point is over
here but somehow it seems that it is
working
and this uh um
uh um uh
this was uh the first paper that came
out of it was in the context of the
double descent i wanna maybe this is
maybe the last thing i'm gonna have time
to do today but i think this is
important to disentangle a bit uh this
issue of double descent versus uh uh
being overfitting not being bad but it's
benign overfitting so right now the
double descend we actually understand
very well there's no issue understanding
double decent the issue is about
anything what i mean by understanding
double descent so we have these plots
um let's say okay we expect something to
go like this this is what i showed you
in this previous graph but what we're
actually seeing when you increase the
capacity of h is first of all the test
error goes up right it's fine but then
there's another distance it goes down
and what's going on here this is was
pointed out by uh um
a very influential uh an important paper
but let's try to understand what's going
on with this double decision so what
when when we say capacity right there
when they're thinking of this is a
cartoon but they backed it up with those
results their measure of capacity is
again dimension and specifically they're
talking about something maybe even as
simple as this uh linear regression
model okay
uh so we have this linear regression
model that the they're minimizing the
test er the training error which is just
the squared loss of linear predictor and
what we're plotting here uh is uh uh is
the test error
of this predictive okay
but the thing is that what is this
predictor so they say this predictor is
just
the minimizer of the test loss okay but
what i mean minimizer of the test loss
sorry minimizer of the training loss
what's the minimizer of the training
loss it's not really the minimizer of
the training loss because they obtain it
in a particular way and we already saw
that just saying we're minimizing the
training error especially in this regime
here which is underdetermined it matters
how you minimize the training error
right so in particular um
if they minimized it with grading
descent over uh
with granny said we know they'll get the
minimum predictive they didn't actually
use grading descent how i mean if you
actually needed to use this square
problem right now i give you some data
and they tell you several score problems
how are you going to solve it
writing a metrics oh my god you should
never inverted metrics that's horrible
it's computationally efficient
numerically unstable anyway how are you
going to invert the metrics you're going
to program some gauss elimination what
are you actually going to do on your
anybody has laptop you have a laptop
you're open right i give you now right
now i'm going to give you a usb key with
some data and then you want to solve the
least square problem what are you going
to do in your laptop
with some using
data on it you want to sell at least
work out how are you going to solve
these four problems
on your laptop what are you going to do
you have a laptop what are you going to
make if you have laptop sessions what
are you going to do how are you going to
solve this these score problems
sci-fi right you're not getting further
mentions
okay who's going to use sci-fi okay how
many people have been used by
so the thing is that these things they
actually don't use very nice but they
also use a procedure
um it's a specific american procedure
and what does this do so actually if you
go to the communication for this what
they tell you if you go to the
documentation of uh numpy lists
least square what it does what it says
is if the problem is over determined it
returns the minimum error solution but
if the problem is underdetermined it
returns
the minimum norm solution
right so it actually the documentation
itself admits that it has this it's not
implicit bias at this point it's
explicit bias it says in the
documentation
but really the documentation says there
are two different learning rules here
right on the left-hand side here the
documentation says it minimizes the
error on the right-hand side the
recommendation says oh i'm actually
using a completely different learning
rule the learning really is the
right-hand side is minimum norm solution
okay and so really the reason we get
your two different behavior is because
we're just using two different learning
rules i mean we get both of them with
the same you know uh uh same python
routine or say matlab matlab backs are
same thing okay
but they're really two different
learning rules okay so um
um and so now uh this learning world we
understand how it behaves and now this
learning rule why does this go down well
this is exactly explanation we had
before right and this is exactly the
thing i mean it goes down because uh in
these particular examples the the
complexity control is no longer coming
from the dimensionality this x-axis is
not capacity this x-axis is how well we
approximate okay uh and so we understand
very well that we approximate the the
real normal care about better and better
than we get uh better generalization and
there's no mystery here okay
um and then
what is the
um and i should say
uh okay so what uh what is the mystery
here so this one we understand very well
if we actually are in a situation where
in this realizable situation where the
right thing to do is really to find the
minimum normal solution okay minimum
zero error solution
but the strange thing here is that this
is if we're going to be here the strange
thing here and this is really the thing
the the interesting the super
interesting thing that misha belkin
pointed out
is that
using this
extreme solution this extreme end of the
organization path is working even in
noisy settings even in settings which we
we're definitely overfitting that we
should be balancing but we're not right
so the real mystery is not the descent
it's the fact that
that we're doing
minimum description length we're doing
zero minimum norm zero solution and not
finding a balance in situations which
are noisy so we should find the balance
why why am i saying the situation is
definitely noisy so you already saw an
example uh spencer showed an example uh
yesterday where you just
he knows he knows it's noisy because he
added the noise himself he took a
problem that's linear inseparable okay
fine for that finding a max margin zero
error solution is perfectly fine but
then he added 15 error
so and then he he trains the network he
trains his network
to have zero error i'm gonna go a few
minutes uh over here excuse me to a zero
error so he's definitely overfitting i
know he's overfitting he knows he's
overfitting because there's 15 percent
error and he get it the the true labels
have 15 error and he's getting zero
error which means he's necessarily
fitting the noise that's the definition
of overfitting so he's fitting the noise
okay and never
and and yet somehow even though he's
overfitting he's generalizing fine okay
and so spencer showed us this uh uh
yesterday and again the first uh to
point this out was michel belkin very
explicitly using a you know a very
similar experiment taking data that is
then inseparable adding even very large
amounts of noise
fitting it to zero error and seeing that
you still succeed in learning you know
getting much better than uh
than the null air so what's going on
here is it's not that the overfitting is
helpful here
over here spencer got the same you know
over here he's not yet overfitting and
he already gets uh good error right so
it's not that overfitting helps you get
uh smaller air but it doesn't hurt you
it's benign okay
so revenue you should think of it this
way so the overfitting we saw before
with this polynomial fit was harmful
over fitting it looked like this over
here in order to fit the noise to
overfit i need to work very hard and
really change the function everywhere
and so i completely ruin my
generalization performance
and somehow it seems that in many
settings okay though we're fitting whoa
go back the overfitting is benign so in
many settings the overfitting looks more
like this this is this is also an
overflow this is made up this is a
cartoon right i drew this in powerpoint
this doesn't correspond to a result of
any experiment right but this kind of
captures what's going on did i have a
curve that fits the the signal pretty
well and then in order to fit the noise
i only make tiny changes
that fit that noise part you know i fit
all the noise but without ruining the
fit everywhere else so somehow the
overfitting
that i can fit the noise with a zero
measure effect overall it doesn't have
any effect on random examples okay and
a question we're trying to understand
now i'm going to i had some stuff to say
about it but i'm not going to say it but
that's fine because we're going to hear
two talks this afternoon about the 9
overfitting is exactly understanding
when there's overfitting looks like this
and when does overfitting look like this
okay and let me just jump over all this
uh
okay maybe okay maybe i'll just quickly
without getting into details i can say
that
um
spencer okay just spencer promised you
that i'll talk about it so maybe i will
talk about it um
there's a question of how you know can
you hope to understand overfitting using
you from convergence so usually when you
think about uniform convergence the way
we explain things is we bound the uh the
loss of the return predictor of the
learn predictor by its empirical error
plus the difference between uh the
empirical population which is the uh the
uniform convergence bound and usually
what we say when you do balance learning
we learn a predictor in a way that
the um
the empirical error converges to the
true uh uh you know population or the
kind of
the error of the optimal predictor this
noise level okay and now what we have to
say is this this you know the deviation
goes to zero and that's fine because if
we have bounded complexity and the
number of samples increases and this
deviation goes to zero this is our usual
analysis now the question is do we have
any hope of using this analysis to
analyze uniform conv to analyze uh an
interpolating predictor predictor will
get zero error okay to analyze uh benign
overfitting so again just to get the
terminology interpolating predictor i
mean any particular term is a zero error
predictor and overfitting is benign if
that interpolating predictor actually
generalizes fine okay uh even though
there's noise so now the thing is that
for an interpolating predictor the
training error by definition is going to
be zero
and so this deviation cannot possibly go
down to zero right because i cannot get
error better than the
than the noise level so what i need to
show is that this deviation goes down
exactly to the noise level and this is
very strange like
this is a deviation between two errors
this is not like the noise level how can
it go down magically exactly to the
noise level and if i want to use bounds
for that note that if my bound is off by
a constant factor i'm dead because my
bound is off by a factor of 10 instead
of getting here you know
you know this thing i get 10 times this
right
then i'm going to get
i'm going to get something here which is
10 times the noise level i'm not going
to get consistency and i'm going to show
that i actually get down to the noise
level so i need super precise
generalization guarantees and
nevertheless um
so um what i'm not going to tell you
about today but this is a joint work
with the freddie caller and lisa zhao
and uh danica sutherland and uh recently
also with vera pryor uh we can actually
get uh generalization uniform
convergence guarantees that are tight
enough to help to explain this um let me
jump over all this
[Music]
and just
get to here
and um without explaining everything
like again the goal of all this and this
is what maybe you should keep in mind to
the talks you're going to hear i think
this afternoon because i can
characterize when is overfitting benign
and when is overfitting harmful and for
at least for uh i'll go back to here at
least for um
uh for linear regression uh infinity
infinite dimensional regression we have
a sense of when is overfitting benign
and when is it harmful so in particular
we have a characterization of when is
overfitting benign when is overfilling
for linear regression going to be benign
and they have these uh sufficient
conditions and they say this is uh
essentially going back to a work by
peter bartle and others with some slight
simplifications so we have two
conditions these red conditions in the
green condition so okay
don't look even at this slide because i
didn't tell you just tell you what what
they are because so on one hand we need
the the we need our model
we need reality uh to actually uh we
need
we need our feature space to be such
that its norm of the features doesn't uh
uh increase too much because then if it
doesn't increase too much then the
um uh what happens is that we're gonna
have too high capacity to to even be
able to learn we can't learn so the red
conditions that i'm not telling you are
our conditions have nothing to do with
nine over fitting they're necessary at
all to get consistent using any
predictor the question is when is benign
overfitting gonna work in order to do
that um
when we need is to have many many
features as captured by this effective
rank of our uh uh
of our covariate so this is roughly
comparing the
um
uh uh
the
uh
square of the or the the
the sum of the the square of the sum of
the eigenvalues to this to the square of
the sum to the sum of the score of the
eigenvalues so if at least all the
eigenvalues the same is exactly the
dimensionality and what we need is this
for this dimensionality to increase to
be super linear in number of samples we
need it to be very easy to fit the the
noise
if it's very easy to fit the noise then
we're going to just fit it using these
spikes this is roughly what's going on
here you probably didn't understand any
of this i would not understand it in
this explanation but the thing is that
this allows us to really understand and
characterize in different situations
depending on the spherical decay
when is overfitting benign like we have
here right so this is the situation so
the the red line here is the uh the
population risk when
um it's uh uh so okay so now this is
important so i told you the problem with
this double descend curve okay this is
actually the reason i want to show this
f slide this is the last side is because
the x-axis was wrong the x-axis did not
plot capacity like it was claimed the
x-axis plugs plotted you know uh uh
precision of approximation okay so now
i'm showing you with the correct x-axis
what i mean the correct x-axis this
correct axis does correspond to capacity
what i'm actually plotting here is
lambda it's the regression parameter but
note that you know when the
regularization parameter
is large as it is here then the
predictor has very small norm and norm
he is the correct capacity and then when
i increase it i get smaller and smaller
larger and larger norm predictor so this
x-axis here is monotone in the norm
which is the correct capacity measure
here okay
in in
in benign overfitting we see that even
if we have very very large norm
predictors okay um
then we do not overfit right because you
know sorry we do overfit but overfitting
is benign we we don't get uh the the
generalization doesn't hurt us doesn't
suffer
whereas in harmal overfitting what
happens is that there is this blue line
is the correct balance right this is the
optimal balance on the i have this plot
uh yet no sorry i didn't understand so
this blue line corresponds to correct
balance between fit and
norm and in both cases this works well
the thing is that what happens in benign
overfitting it doesn't hurt us to oh to
under regularize doesn't hurt us to use
a larger and larger norm doesn't hurt us
to overfit we don't gain anything but we
don't lose either we don't gain much
in we're in other cases when the
spectral decay is is too fast
uh the overfitting is harmful okay um
this is kind of what we want to look the
difference in these two behaviors okay
so this is um
and and we can understand it and also i
think what we're going to be here this
afternoon is this uh uh dichotomy of
benign overfitting and harmful
overfitting is a bit too crude because
what actually happens frequently is that
overfitting is not completely
destructive it doesn't completely ruin
your ear but it's not completely benign
either it hurts you but it only hurts
you a bit and i think we'll be hearing
it talk about this this afternoon right
uh whereas the speakers i don't know all
right okay
right that uh okay good um okay uh oh
that's the plot that i wanted
yeah so this okay maybe i'm going to say
this again because this is i think
important right what we're seeing here
this the x-axis here corresponding to
traversing
this pareto frontier okay and we know
that we should be at this point okay
that's the open point that's what our
classical theory tells us this is this
blue line okay and this point is fine
either way the real question is what
happens if i go past this point and i've
been harmful for overfitting i really
have to be exactly on that point i start
if i go past this point this is under
fitting here and this is overfitting
under fitting is always bad shrinkage
and here overfitting in a harmful
overfitting situation overfitting is
also bad okay
but in the benign overfitting situation
it's fine to overfit so this is in a
practical sense this is the main
implication we don't have to be so
careful about getting the best balance
we don't have to be so super careful
about getting the exact lambda this
entire range of lambdas this entire
region on the on the pareto frontier is
going to be just as good
um okay
let me end here we're already almost 10
minutes over time
and
just to summarize um
mostly what i wanted to convey to you we
did talk also a bit about uh
this organization there's you know lots
of more uh to say uh but mostly what i
wanted to con to uh to give you is
really when we we think about this is
before jumping to conclusion of
something you know we have to like throw
away everything we had and start from
scratch
you know we actually learned quite a bit
in like you know several decades of uh
thinking about uh machine learning and
physical learning theory and
most of uh
um the phenomenon we see fit perfectly
with within our existing understanding
we know how to learn using over
parameterized models we know how you can
get you know you can get complexity
control from scale rather than size we
know how it can come
implicitly from the optimization
algorithm we just need to answer the
questions of okay how does this actually
play out
in deep learning what is the actual
complexity control you know and how well
does it correspond to reality one thing
that we definitely think and we are
thinking as evident by several talks
this workshop is is uh this phenomenon
of benign overfitting it's not specific
to deep learning and we also looking
back it was in front of our eyes you
know at least since the 90s and you can
see it in these classic uh boosting
results i should say also it was in
front of our eyes in those experiments
from um you can even see the double
descender if you look carefully in the
experiments from eight years ago we were
blind to it okay so now i can say you
know also
i personally was blind to it and so this
phenomenon is not special specific to
deep learning but it is something that
we thanks to misha just kind of realized
three years ago uh and nearly that that
or four years ago now um and it is
something that we need to uh rethink and
think about and see how
we definitely see it especially in the
context of deep learning
okay that's it thanks
[Applause]
questions
um so i saw the the part about um using
uniform convergence to explain banana
overfitting i was wondering in general
do you think that um uniform convergence
is still the right structure for i mean
plus implicit bias is still the right
structure for explaining generalization
especially in light of you know kind of
the results okay thanks for reminding me
i didn't put out the last bullet oh yeah
well that was my question
that was my question that's the question
in my answer
okay uh this was not planned seriously
he planted me in the audience
so uh but uh um i did the lunch after
that
so um
i'm not sure so maybe i definitely think
that you can get quite away with the
uh within from convergence we we are
able
in fact for specifically for benign
overfitting we can uh
uh we can explain much of it with over
with the
uniform convergence in fact
it's also so the other approaches are
kind of these direct approaches to study
specific method uh we suggested using it
from convergence and then others
including somebody that's here i can see
here right now
followed
and this is a work by fenny yang and
students and i oh run your name
right
constantine has work that also uses that
for l1 uh minimum l1 arm predictors and
this is advantage of uniform convergence
and once we have this generic guarantee
we can plug it in into lots of different
hypothesis classes lots of different
complexity measures and a lot can be
gained from that it's still not clear
whether really
we can explain everything we want using
uniform convergence i mean they're
definitely you can construct synthetic
situations in which you cannot okay so
we know the neutron convergence is not
so this is also work uh this
uh to me it was very surprising we
discovered this like already 10 years
ago that actually there are things you
can learn but you can probably not learn
them using your different convergence so
some synthetic there are definitely
exist synthetic situations like that and
i'm not sure how much of deep learning
specifically we can explain with that or
not so both for benign overfitting and
also as i mentioned before this
complexity theory approach breaking down
things to saying okay let's identify
complexity measure and now understand
its capacity you know using it from
convergence tools i there are many
things i know we can explain this way i
expect that there are many more things
we can explain this way but it's not
clear
whether it can really explain you know
everything we want to explain or we have
to go beyond that so i guess a little
bit more philosophically do you think
that we need a framework that can
explain everything even synthetic
situations or do you think it's
sufficient that the framework can
explain reality
yes and yes
so
it's a
it really varies so if
as a
mathematician in some sense i know i
feel like saying a mathematician is a
bit uh presumptuous
i want to understand learning also from
a mathematical perspective like i want
to understand what are the minimal
requirements for learning like what
learning is a mathematical phenomenon so
if you want to understand learning as a
mathematical phenomena i'm definitely
very interested in understanding all the
edge cases you know understanding when
does uniform convergence provably fail
okay um what other things are okay is
stability always sufficient we don't
know okay is you know a strict convexity
in some sense always sufficient i really
am interested in that
if
i put on my engineering hat on and i
want to understand deep learning i think
as if an engineer it's important to
understand actually
what you're doing
then now really i should ask is you know
is uniform convergence or whatever other
approaches sufficient for understanding
this phenomena i don't really care about
the edge cases
still studying the edge case is
important because like you know
informs me about maybe i should be
looking another way but you know the
fact that there is an edge case doesn't
mean that i should stop using uniform
convergence because maybe i can get it
you know understand a lot of
things with it right so it's so i think
both are important
in uniform convergence we consider the
training set is
a random random samples right but in
practice we usually
have a
fixed training set so is that
conflict i don't know what it means for
a fixed rating so it doesn't make any
sense for you to have a fixed training
set if you want to study learning
learning only
you know you that training set
you know
came from somewhere you have to make
some assumption
about you have to you know not just
assumption like you you have to have
some relationship between your training
set and what it is you're trying to
predict you know
it can be um saying that that training
set was drawn from the same distribution
as reality which is the assumption we
make here you can also weaken that
assumption either still stay within a
probabilistic framework but like weaken
the idea assumption of the fact that
it's run from the same distribution or
maybe
depart from the probabilistic framework
uh and talk about like something like
online regret right so so that's a
different type of assumption about how
your training data is related to what
you're trying to predict
but you have to relate your training
data to what you're trying to predict
it's meaningless to just say i have a
training set i'm not going to assume
anything about it let's see how running
a training algorithm in that is going to
work on something completely different
so i don't really know what it means to
use a fixed training set and and this is
in particular
you know so this is something that
actually i mean i think important when
you when you look previous that when you
look at
when you uh
when you you think of your you you you
define your learning algorithm the
training set already fixed
it doesn't really make sense to right
the the the training set is not part of
the of the of the learning algorithm
otherwise what is a learning rule like
to me a learning rule is a mapping from
training set to
you know to the predictors it's not if
the lingual just outputs something
constant i don't know how how to think
about it how that makes sense
if that
answers your question right so i mean
the way i think of reality right i mean
when you say you learn you use a fixed
training set so in reality you don't use
the fixed training set you collect data
right and use that data i mean you you
have your learning role before you
collect the data right that's actually
how you use you write that when you're
doing writing papers in mnist then the
training set is fixed but writing
training papers on the mnist training
set doesn't make any sense
right i mean it's the only way it makes
sense if you think of the mnist data is
sampled from somewhere maybe and in fact
also there you get maybe into some
trouble because we're kind of way over
fitting that
does that maybe
so you're defining overfitting as
fitting noise but what if it's not
actually noise it's just something
that's no is this is fitting something
yeah so it's hard to have a mathematical
definition of overfitting um
at least in in the simple cases i have
here where the data is generated by a
predictor in the class plus noise then
my defining is fitting the norms
generally i define overfitting is
fitting the part
of the data that cannot be um
that you cannot that goes beyond what
you uh
you can
you can fit beyond what you can explain
using your effective uh
uh hypothesis hypothesis which have high
enough capacity right this is a vague
definition right so it's not like um i i
can't uh i i don't i i can't write i
can't give a
generic mathematical definition of
overfitting and i
don't
i'm not aware of anything like that i
don't think that's possible but
i think we have one final question
thank you i was curious do you have a
sense of i'm like interested in like
pac-bays versus uniform convergence and
do you have any sense of base is uniform
convergence
it's it's not uniform convergence in the
sense that it gives you a bound on the
expected risk of a distribution of
classifiers rather than a worse case
it's uniform convergence no it is worth
it
but it's always basically pack base is
uniform convergence pack base gives you
okay
so i'm not sure which why you're
objecting to think of a different
convergence there might be two reasons
and neither of them i think is uh
three reasons in in none of them is okay
so one thing is you get uh the your
the predictors you're getting you're
doing infinite convergence not over
individual predictors but over aggregate
predictors fine but still family of
predictors it's still you from
convergence right the second thing is um
that the right hand side uh depends on
the so you get a guarantee or the right
side depends on the predictor but again
that's not we saw that that we get that
uh
you know it's the same way
saying that i can get it i'd still call
it uniform convergence over uh uh low
norm predictors or the right-hand side
depends on the norm right that's because
i'm just looking at sub-level sets same
thing in with the pac-bays i can
rephrase in a completely equivalent
statement of the back base and saying if
the kl divergence is bounded i get a
guarantee with the right-hand side is
fixed so that's still definitely from
convergence maybe the third reason
you're bothered by and that's something
i i skipped here is the right hand side
also depends on the empirical uh on the
empirical error of the predictor and
again that's a
a very fairly standard thing we're still
calling it from convergence again if you
uh you know in fact if you open uh any
learning
all learning theory books i'm aware of
and all the good ones at least uh the
first example they give uniform
convergence is
realizable case they say how do we
analyze a
get
learning guarantee in the realizable
case would make say finite cardinality
we take a union bound to get uniform
convergence grantee over zero
zero training error predictors so
they're already putting the right-hand
side depends on the on the norm on the
air of the predictor you can generalize
it and have the right-hand side depend
in a more sophisticated way in the error
of the predictor that's still from my
perspective uniform convergence
guarantee so i'm not sure which of these
three bother you but pack base is
definitely from convergence guarantee
well i guess i would distinguish between
a soup over a particular class or an
average and that like a bound on the
average arrow
the bound is over the soup not over the
average
you spec base gives you you have a soup
over all aggregations of predictors it's
definitely a soup it's right but but an
aggregation of protectors can contain
the only it's uniform it's uniform not
over
just over your individual predictors
it's uniform over aggregate predictors
but those aggregate predictors are just
predictors just a different class of
predictors it's like saying that you get
it's like saying that uniform
convergence over linear predictors it's
not uniform because the predictors are
not individual features or aggregate
over features that's exactly the same
type of aggregation right so it's it's
definitely from convergence
backpack base is definitely uniform
convergence guarantee i i i mean i'm not
sure
so what is the fact that you're the
predictors are aggregate okay we should
we can take this offline thanks
so i think we're resuming at 2 30. okay
thanks let's thank nat again
you